[Music]
so tachanka is widely considered rainbow
six siege's
worst operator his colleagues think he
sucks his pros are largely outweighed by
his cons
and the only reason he ever gets picked
is for the sake of dishing out some
major bm
that's that's not that's not real that's
that's
oh wow he actually lost exactly ladies
and gentlemen it's happened
and despite sitting in the corner for
the past five years yelling about his
lmg
the morning he's ascended to godhood
assembling legions of fans who pray at
his lordly altar and cosplay him
whenever they get the chance
he's risen as a rabidly adored cult
figure in spite of the fact that he is a
complete
pylon of an operator that is until now
tachaka has been reborn
and reworked he's unmounted loaded and
mobile
he's the same lord to chanka at heart
he's just demanded to be taken
seriously kind of
[Music]
as any self-respecting siege fan will
tell you the game that launched in 2015
took a long time to figure out what it
actually wanted to be
setting aside the overall health of the
gameplay even the operators in siege
took a while to develop the
personalities that we now know and love
and tachanka represents both sides of
this in a game built around mobility and
being flexible with strategy
he stuck out like a sore thumb now
tachenka has a big old dome head that
stands out by
miles and unlike many of the other
characters with high armor in this game
he doesn't have a shield like the
attackers do to protect this head
this is made worse by the fact that his
gadget or special ability is to place a
stationary turret down
this means that as if your head wasn't
easy enough to hit you're staying still
the inability to balance him got so bad
that the siege development team
even just considered deleting him from
the game entirely but his reputation as
a terrible operator paved the way for
his celebrity his inability to evolve
with the game
over time led to this cult-like status
at its core tachenka wasn't viable but
not in a way that was disruptive
like he was underpicked and had fewer
wins than
all of the other operators the whole
purpose of reworking him
is to take this character who is
probably one of the most recognizable in
siege
and keep what made him special
not only on the lower side but we also
wanted to respect
kind of the community's view of him as
well fast forward a few years and
ubisoft announced this reworked and
jacked version of tachanka
at a panel during the 2020 siege
invitational a panel that signified the
dawn of a new era for the game
so we decided to get back on the drawing
board and uh we were
we're working at tashanka
and while it teased the subdued version
of what our lord is now capable of
in action this reworked version of
tachanka feels like a dank god of chaos
who's been unleashed upon the world of
siege
tachanka's rework kit has transformed
him from being a giant turd who stunk up
the place
into essentially a russian rambo he's
got a grenade launcher that fires
10 bounceable incendiary grenades that
create fires that last up to 5
seconds and while the lord has
sacrificed his monopod he retains his
incredibly powerful
lmg but this time as a goddamn primary
weapon
so yes t'chaka keeps his insane
destructibility
but now he has a degree of mobility that
we've never seen before
and on top of that the russian terror
even borrowed zofia's withstand ability
allowing players to pick themselves back
up after being downed
people were so stoked on the idea of a
t'chaka rework that
in typical siege fashion hackers found
him deep in ubisoft's code
and busted him out prior to his release
but while his reworked kit
is pretty sweet the biggest question on
everyone's mind isn't related to his
grenade launcher or his newfound
mobility no
the biggest question on everyone's mind
is why now
we always had this kind of knowledge
we've tried to make
adjustments to him but we never really
had the means to address it
so we started in earnest around december
2018
to actually look at just reworking
tachenka
his gadget kind of from the ground up of
course
you can't just slap together a new kit
and some fresh dialogue and call it a
day
not with somebody as revered as tachanka
so for years ubisoft has been working
behind the scenes
carefully planning and developing his
resurrection and as excited as people
are
about this new version of tachanka
there's also a segment of the community
who are afraid this rework might
diminish the lord we know and love
there's a concern that tachanka might be
swinging too far back in the opposite
direction
an all-powerful god who now plays like
one and when it comes to his self-res
ability ubisoft is flirting with the
ever-present threat of power creator
i just wish that they settled with you
know he has you know his lmg primary and
he has his new gadget which is a really
good gadget like i
i really don't think he needs to
withstand to stand out
and it just adds more levels of
balancing on
a game that is already heavily
criticized for its balancing no matter
what your take is on this new improved
tachanka
there's no denying how big of a deal
this is to the community
tachanka is siege and siege is tachanka
he's become symbolic of everything we
love and hate about the game since its
release
which is why there's been so much
nervous anticipation around this rework
over the past five years tachanka's
experienced this
weird archetypal hero's journey that's
culminated in him leveling up into the
ultimate
badass what's dope about this rework is
that it has the potential to give
t'chaka the unironic respect
he's deserved all along fans can still
bask in the glow of his divine
memory but his new found viability will
make him
far more than a joke in game
[Music]
you